bienvenue l'impact de montréal comme le
nom est libre on est décidé de se
l'approprier
exit la notice bonjour l'impact comme
disait joey saputo avoir un impact
allait retirer la notice on parle du non
pas de second set après la première
victoire du canadien en 2021
brendan gallagher a demandé qu'on joue
d'une école bac pour célébrer dans le
vestiaire des copains copains ont pu
ramener pk subban comme dj du vestiaire
du canadien
c'est qu'elle se jette encore un peu
sensible mais ça se danse nick layton de
queen sauf qu'un gros est-ce que des
jeux et films sur chaque fougue passée
quad 700 fois la même chose le canadien
désormais son rasoir masculin officiel
et c'est pas pour là bas quand je vois
ross brawn se garder d'actes rapstar est
d'attiser la attaquant des flyers zia
cobra tchèque en règle ses comptes avec
le journaliste maxime ski en conférence
de presse jean en faisant que peu
importe qu'ils diraient ils écriraient
de la merde
avant de traiter 2 8t une hermine un
furet une marque un blaireau 1 vise en
outre clairement toutes les mustélidés
que je multiplie des sceaux fait un bond
équipe parlant des flyers gritti au
débarqué dans la nouvelle saison comme
une influence euse à paillettes exhibant
à tous son nombril preuve qu'il est
magnifique
d'après moi ton louise auger gritti ce
qu'était belhadj et puis qu'est ce que
les gens pensent à la maison d'ailleurs
comme les arènes sont vides gritti a
décidé de souligner le premier tour du
chapeau des flyers en lançant une grosse
casquette sur la glace mais juste après
des années d'attenté et de villon a
enfin dévoilé la première bande annonce
de space jam 2 avec lebron james c'est
tout c'est tout ce qu'on a vu c'est
toute la bande annonce
j'espère juste qu'on peut montrer la
nôtre promenons nouvelles du vatican le
pape francs soit 1 penny le chandail des
hawks d'atlanta en l'honneur de martin
luther king
peut-être que joey saputo aura besoin de
la même bénédiction papale pour le cf
mourir un peu importe
j'aimerais bien voir un pape donkey en
soutane parce que cette semaine on l'a
vu que c'était possible de le faire avec
un hidjab ou john abbott
[Musique]
non vraiment j'ai été un peu surpris de
pas en voir la critique dans une
chronique de ce futur jeu
comme quoi ce fillon peut jouer au
basket comme journaliste en portant
hidjab plus de 70 joueurs de tennis ont
été confinés à leur arrivée en australie
parce qu'une personne dans leur vol
était positive à côté 19e comme elles
sont deux semaines sans pouvoir sortir
de leurs chambres d'hôtel avant le
premier tournoi majeur de la saison
certains ont été assez créatifs pour
rendre leurs matelas comme partenaire
d'entraînement c'est tout pour nous on
voulait sur des images exclusives du
certes montréal nouveaux flocons
merci nous écouter si vous aimez les
notifs vous pouvez toujours partager
cette vidéo à quelqu'un qui va aimer
aussi la nati face au proche orient
dedans sacrebleu c'est une expression de
flibustiers